you ever have that movie that you really
can't stand but everybody else seems to
love and maybe it's not just one movie
maybe it's a couple of movies and maybe
you suddenly become really famous by
doing a stupid hair net show and maybe
everybody judges you by those movies
they're always like oh oh you can't like
that movie or you can't like that movie
good no but no we have to judge it now
get your a pussy you're an asshole then
I hate you I'll never judge you again
either the most print out you get the
idea so what I'm trying to get across
here is that there are movies that I
can't stand they just they get under my
skin but a lot of other people seem to
like them and that's fine it's really
cool don't go around judging people by
this it's not worth it just because you
like a film or don't like a film doesn't
mean you're an idiot or you're not smart
or you're jerk or anything like that and
the prove it I am going to do the top 10
films that I can't stand but everybody
else seems to enjoy have you think oh
that's not fair next week I'm going to
do the top 10 films that I like and
everybody else seems to hate so I'm
doing this just to show it's all opinion
it doesn't say anything about whether or
not you're a good person or a bad person
or a smart person or a dumb person
it's just opinion and what you like to
me what matters is how well you can
explain it so with that said I'm going
to explain why these top ten films I
can't stand they drive me nuts but
everyone else seems to enjoy them so
without further ado let's get started
number ten cars al am i the only one who
thinks this is a terrible idea
I guess when you hear it you think
that's a satire of a Pixar film it
doesn't even sound like a Pixar film
it's like hey we got a lot of people and
they're all cars they're all cars oh the
possibility of jokes I can't recall one
good car joke in this movie the only
joke I recall that was kind of funny was
when at the very beginning when they're
all leaving and the woman's room has
this really long line of cars that was
kind of funny but outside of that why
were they all cars you could make them
anything it didn't matter you can make
them race car drivers it would have been
fine the other thing that really bothers
me is that before this film The
Incredibles came out and Pixar always
had trouble getting people down they
always sort of looked like these weird
plastic puppets and that's why they kept
doing an avid objects or bugs or
whatever uh in The Incredibles they got
people down really good they looked like
three-dimensional cartoons and they were
awesome heals like the first time you
saw a cartoon character in 3d and it was
great man the possibilities you can do
with this what do they do cars it just
seemed like a huge step backwards to me
and that's not the only thing that
annoys me the other thing that annoys me
is that it's a very basic guy in the
high life suddenly gets dragged down to
the slums and he appreciates the value
of hard work and stuff and seen that
story to death nothing new outside the
fact that their cars which is not that
exciting so um it just didn't do
anything for me and I know a lot of
people like it to be fair it's not
god-awful it's not like a horrible film
they just seemed like there was nothing
to it so again a lot of people like a
lot kids enjoy it there's a sequel
coming out so hopefully it's better at
their secret agents now or something I
don't know so I mean thankfully after
cars they when they did ratatouille and
they kept expanding what they can do
with you know actual humor
when they're not just whatever
rotoscoping them in wall-e uh so yeah
I'm I'm glad to see they're going in
whatever better direction up which of
course was great so yeah that just
seemed like a real step back where I
said to see a sequel this was popular
enough to get a sequel I don't
understand it but that doesn't mean you
don't have to understand it so that's
cars number nine gladiator I am NOT a
Russell Crowe fan but that's not why I
don't like this movie I don't like this
movie because again it's a story that's
been done to death it's the Moses story
the guy on top of the world
betrayed or whatever by someone really
close dragged down to the slums has to
work his way back up so he can get his
righteous revenge and very very bland
the only thing that kind of entertaining
is Joaquin Phoenix as the villain cuz
he's so over-the-top I think there's one
point where he's watching the you know
the mole fight Egypt goes haha I like
love it absolutely love it um but
outside of that it's just your typical
bland hero chops up people and gets the
bad guy and which I wouldn't mind if the
characters were interesting they're not
very interesting I did particularly crow
he's just the generic good guy and I
always feel bad for Ridley Scott because
I get the feeling he can make good
movies like he tries to give his
characters death they tried to a no more
but he's still picking scripts that are
just it's the bland story there's
nothing needed to it he's trying to add
meat to you know just bare bones and
which okay it's decent challenge but it
doesn't always work so but for whatever
reason people really got into it it does
look nice for the most part um fight
scenes are kind of cool but if you don't
give a crap about them you know if you
don't give a crap about the people you
don't give a crap about what they're
fighting for so and when a character
dies you know
you're supposed to feel and nothing I
mean I barely felt like I got to know
these people um you know Jin they're go
over the top villain sometimes little
depth um really Scout always seems to be
doing ideally he'll start to get dead
they'll start to be interesting and they
just goes into cliche again so um not a
fan
definitely don't think a deserve Best
Picture but I really agree with the
Oscars anyway so um yeah so that's my
thought on gladiator number eight
American Pie now this movie came out
during that gross-out era of comedy that
will probably come back again sometime
but hopefully it'll be done better
because this was this was during uh
there's something about Mary that became
a huge hit huge big groundbreaking
gross-out movie everyone tried to copy
it and what the movies trying to copy
what they missed about their self about
Mary and American Pie missed as well is
that the comedy does not come from the
gross-out humor that's not what's funny
it's funny that the gross-out humor is
happening to these characters it's funny
when it happens to Ben Stiller because
we like him but he's weird and pathetic
it's funny what happens to Matt Dillon
cuz he's such a jerk but we enjoy hating
him and these weird story twists that it
takes you know with all this it just
adds to the strangeness that is why that
movie worked American Pie just seemed
like generic geeks and jocks that was
about in there just bland character as
we've seen a million times and they're
not the star of the movie they are not
the focus
it's the gross-out humor that's the
focus the only person I got a lot of
laughter from was a Eugene Levy as the
father he was great uh the other reason
I really hate it is because they start
off making this pact that they're gonna
get laid before whatever senior year is
out and then by the end they say you
know what fuck it we don't need to do
this you know what sex should be a
special thing that we do when we're
ready and we want to have it with that
special person it shouldn't be a contest
good for you movie good message good
thing to send out to teenage kids and
they feel pressure about it
stuff what they do they all sleep with
people that very night so there was the
message out the window just totally gone
so it didn't have a good message or a
try but totally failed um didn't think
it was very funny I I guess I liked that
made a few stars out of this
um but yeah where I spawned from I
thought was a very weak unfunny place so
I get maybe you left great not of it
number seven avatar okay you've all
heard me bitch and moan about this movie
um but it's actually pretty low on the
list because there's some good things
about it I like the scenery it's very
nice scenery now if you ever look at
sci-fi illustrations it's nothing new
but it's nice to see it on the big
screen I did like the 3d I thought it
was pretty cool but again How to Train
Your Dragon came out maybe a month later
a few months later totally blew it away
I mean unbelievable 3d best I've ever
seen
so doesn't have that going for it and of
course what I really hate is the story
and even people that like this movie say
the story's not that good good I
understand I understand
guilty pleasures you know I understand
they want to be sucked into the
environment stuff like that but the
technology identity is anything that's
spectacular sometimes it looked like it
was really there but I was almost always
aware I'm looking at computers these are
computer images they're very nice
looking but they move like computers the
texture looks like computers it's still
computers I never felt like hey I can
reach out and touch these people only
once or twice and to be fair they're
blue tats how are you going to make that
look real so granted it's a challenge
and to make that come alive I guess they
did pretty well but for everyone to be
building it up like that I thought it
wasn't really worth it but I think the
number one thing that annoys me about
this movie it really is the story but
the reason is that we have heard this
story so many times
Pocahontas firm galling dancer with wool
it was old when those movies did it and
to have now now this movie coming out
and becomes the highest-grossing movie
of all time that is telling these
studios we want more of this story we
want to hear this story again and again
and again I can't believe that I just I
think we know the story people who watch
it even admit that the story is not very
good and I think by by making it the
highest-grossing movie we really say hey
bring us more of this bring us more of
this story you know this is new to us
and that's what gets to me is that
there's already Avatar sequels being
made it's probably gonna be that same
story over and over and I don't mind
stories about prejudice or the big man
you know whatever using his power over
the smaller man it's go into why why are
they like that you know go into you know
we know the story don't judge got it
we've been told this since kindergarten
we know the story unless you're gonna
give us something new instead of just
replacing the Native Americans with blue
pussies it's not going to be very
interesting so I would like to see a
movie that goes into why these people on
these prejudices exist you know or greed
why do we think that you know to get
this valuable stuff whatever the obvious
gold or oil whatever it was um is more
important than human life that would be
interesting that would be new this movie
doesn't do it it tells us a story we've
seen a million times you can predict it
from the first minute to the last minute
just annoy me but look nice
number six with honors I this is an
Armando's man I want to punch this movie
this movie tries so hard to be that
underground you know oh if only we
listened if only we were aware you know
you have Joe Pesci playing this bum this
incredibly obnoxious you want to kick
him in the nuts bum but oh he's not bad
he's just misunderstood because we won't
listen no I know what he is he is a tool
he is a tool of the movie to make us
feel bad for him so that we can feel
like big jerks and Harvard apparently
has these programs that go out and help
people who are homeless and stuff like
that they go out and they help these
people and they never talk about that
the professors are the stereotypical
professors with the time the puffed out
chosen you have no idea what's going on
and I hate that I hate that they see
this bum I hate that this bum keeps
saying oh boy oh boy like they're trying
to get that catchphrase in your head I
hate the fact that you know as soon as
you see this bum where it's gonna go
that the kid is gonna be friends and
he's gonna find out something about
himself and he's gonna find out that
this bum oh he was a kind soul just he
sad events I shouldn't judge and hmm
there's one good scene it's not even a
good scene it's a horrible scene the
speech is really good though
there's the speech about the
Constitution that Joe Pesci says I think
the whole movie was just written for
this speech I think someone came up with
this speech and said that's a really
good speech really something how can I
write a movie around that and he just
thought up the most cliched plot ever
and the speech is really good the movie
that was made around it is crap it
sounds like it was just written on a
cocktail napkin you know what else can
we rip off here so really really didn't
like this may is sort of that
and I just shit
number five signs
now of course M night Shyamalan has
become the punchline of directors pretty
much I mean his movies people aren't
just hating him more and more
but what really shocked me is how many
people liked science and that is so
curious because I think that's one of
his funny ones that that's where his
feelings start to become funny you know
a sixth sense everybody loves
unbreakable people are mixed about it
but even people that don't like it could
at least take it seriously if you'd
given the subject matter signs is where
it starts to get hilarious and yeah
where do I start with this movie these
aliens are allergic to water water is
what kills them they attack this planet
that is mostly water whoops they master
as scary movie three point they master a
space travel but they can't get through
a wooden door um all the kids talk like
adults all the adults talk like kids
nobody talks right in this movie uh the
message spoiler the message that God was
trying to get to Mel gifts in all this
time the reason he killed his wife which
made him leave the faith which must've
meant he wasn't a good priest anyway cuz
no priest would leave you know for that
because the wife's dead and Oh God
took her you better idiot priest um but
it does it's okay because the message
that God was trying to get to her was so
that years later when these idiot aliens
come down and try to attack the kid she
was giving him a message in the future
to say swing the bat at the alien that
that defeats the alien about they water
and a bath these are the most pusseh
fight aliens ever these are terrible
aliens they do not do well at their job
um and then at the very end what I love
kids dying of a asthma attack oh really
really bad I mean he's at death's door
pretty much and Mel gets it you know
there's a truck called ambos
no no no just believe believe boom you
know got a bit of an egotist isn't he
gotta be like you know you may want call
nice you but you may want to do sit
really you're just gonna be chanting my
name
okay he's what the kid live just
believing in God save this kid from
dying of an asthma attack and I was just
thinking about um this movie actually
have now you know nowadays might be
outta this might be along the same level
as like devil or the happening and then
stuff like that I think watch this movie
again I bet you I bet you this is gonna
have maybe another uprising of fans who
enjoy it because of how bad it is
and that'd be really interesting because
it does sort of deserve it the only
thing that I thought was a really good
touching moment I like when NGOs in our
asthma attack see I think the alien
tried to grab the kid but Gibson gives
him away and the kids having an asthma
attack and Gibson Saint breathe with me
Brady he's trying to control his
breathing by having him listen to his
breed and that that was very nice that
was a very and that I could believe cuz
that's like logical that's listen even
though I don't know if asthma attacks
worked that way probably not but the
scene still work it was a very nice
touching scene um and he had to do
something he didn't just a police so um
and I get nice plan of God to have no
gifts and leave the faith just so he can
come back again all costume was a wife
so yeah I you know what I might actually
like this movie I think of it this might
that would be a really funny movie um
I'm gonna have to watch this again I
might take this off the list later if I
watch it again that's um that's pretty
funny
number four now this is one of those
movies where you know the only reason
was made was so the main actress could
get an Academy Award she produced it
Joey foster produced as she accent it
interesting idea the idea is that this
mentally challenged young woman lives in
the the woods her mother dies and she's
left out there and they're wondering too
should they bring her to a you know a
mental institution or should they just
leave her out there can she take care of
herself and but she speaks her own
language the mother was very very
southern you know had a very thick
accent and the the language they had to
sort of decode because it's sort of
jumbled but they're making out it is
English it's just very sort of slanted
English now that's really interesting
that's a cool idea uh but of course what
happens got monotone Liam Neeson comes
out there and gets too involved this
other woman doctor who of course was
praying that what they're gonna fall in
love we know that um you got Jodie
Foster just every second you know just
looking oh I'm confused and curious but
innocent you know Oscar face you know
it's another one of generic you know
actors that play a mentally challenged
people who are obviously fishing for an
Oscar this is definitely one of those
movies and the sort of redneck bad guys
they have in this movie are beyond
over-the-top I made these guys like just
the way they talk it makes no sense if
there's one scene where Nell runs into a
bar it sounds like a joke and she runs
in and the redneck guys are they're like
oh hey it's her the girl from the other
cabin home hey shows you bros for you
who are there making fun of her and
she's you know funny huh and eventually
for whatever reason were uh childlike
mine she raises up her dress and flashes
everybody now of course in any redneck
bar what would happen
everybody got tips we love tits we all
know that what happened in here no
Renick people there disturb
and what they said you my somebody's do
what I
she blew my mind total crazy makes no
sense at the end I Liam Neeson's
performance is almost as bad as Joey
Faust no actually it is worse that's the
worst performing Jodie Foster is looking
for an Oscar Liam Neeson doe it a lot of
scientist who gets emotionally involved
in a penny dropped over poor pity you
know I mean just gets way involved too
fast you know way too emotionally
involved and you know everything doesn't
know they don't understand I have to you
know she can't stay out there because no
no she she can't stay in the mental
institution because uh you know she
she's running into walls and flashing
people and something that she's fine
just misunderstood
it's obvious this person at least should
be looked at you know by a mental
institution you know just pull them in
there and just say okay let's let's see
you know you know what other doctors
outside of just these two look at her to
the interest in case anyway and the big
thing is the publicity if the media will
be all over her and that'll ruin her
life and sighs she barely has an idea of
what the media is and if anything Liam
Neeson desire doctor building up the
media and like trying to drive her away
cuz there's a chopper that comes after
her this news chopper with the camera
cut it can't be that boring on news day
people and they're chasing her down like
it's an action scene and it's the fact
that Liam Neeson this other doctor are
building up how bad the media is that
you know that's what's doing the damage
the median sell price of doing anything
you know cuz she doesn't watch TV anyway
and all this crap is going on there's a
scene with Liam Neeson is carrying her
out of the mental hospital I mean just
pure white knight bullshit there's a
scene in the courtroom think that's not
courtroom scene where she like leaves
our case and stuff like that it's
terrible terrible movie people love it
no idea why um doesn't do anything for
me
uh if you're touched by it more power to
you
uh I couldn't stand it again just show
you the difference number three
Matilda now here's a funny thing I
originally was gonna do this as a
nostalgia critic for view people freaked
they're like you do not touch that
fucking movie you mother this movie must
hit a chord with a lot of people because
I mean there's like uproar of people
that were gonna kill me if I said
anything bad about this movie so I took
it off and I didn't want to piss off
that many people uh but I thought this
was horrendously awful I mean just
really horrible mean movie again anyone
who knows me knows I'm all for dark
movies I love dark humor I adore it
but there has to be a reason for it and
this just seems so needlessly cruel
these are images like putting kids in a
closet with nails you know in the closet
they have to not move or else they get
poked by the nails and this is just in
like a kindergarten class you know or
first grade uh there's a lot of those
weird wide-angle close-ups
you know rip it's like this you see like
the bad teacher like this just ah I'm
gonna eat you yeah and that gets really
old after a while uh is I guess it's
about this girl that has like
supernatural powers I get the fun gonna
be entertaining uh but just very generic
villain very this this plot gets so
stupid with something about uh it's not
the teacher who that the teacher is is
the good guy uh I'm not sure with the
job but there's someone that looks after
the kids like on the playground you know
whatever role that is and they get this
really big ugly woman to play her you
know and to her cramp looks like she's
having a lot of fun but uh they just
make her like the ultimate villain like
I guess she murders somebody in the past
also has a psychological grip on this
teacher it's like what what the hell are
you doing
and have the jokes don't make sense
there's a scene where the woman I think
this girl is doing something like
chewing gum I'll know what she's doing
but she's uh not really misbehaving but
the woman sees as misbehaving so she
grants the girl by her pigtails swings
her around and tosses her I'm like what
the hell is this I have no idea what
this movie is trying to do what's trying
to convey what it is just for me it's a
disaster of a movie and what really
pisses me off I hate it when it's for
kids I hate it when there's a movie
trying to be really dark and for kids
and it fails because that's will it's
sending bad messages it could be fucking
up your kid you know I mean it could
really be Oh fucking a mob cuz I said
dog stuff for kids isn't bad love Return
to Oz secret name all that stuff but
they're good and they have good messages
and they have good characters this is
just a nasty movie just really nasty
really unpleasant did like looking at it
didn't like hearing it didn't like the
story didn't like the characters didn't
like any of it and it was directed by
Danny DeVito who as far as I'm concerned
erected one good movie and that's War of
the Roses and that is a great movie but
he really likes the being dark just to
be dark and getting weird shots and
weird angles just to have weird shots
and weird angles it doesn't create a
good environment or good atmosphere I
it's if it is saying something nobody
knows what the shots are trying to say
and I I really hated this way like I
said become OWSLA because it's for kids
and that that really gets under my skin
when somebody puts out a very nasty mean
hate-filled movie that whatever has a
happy ending so the dog blew the
principal must work um but it I didn't
like it that that's all I can say about
it
number two district nine as is another
one people just go nuts when I say I
didn't like it it why how could you not
like this way this is an innovative
brand new nobody's ever done before
everybody has done this movie and it is
it's when I was saying ah movies I've
already been done for Avatar Pocahontas
dance with a Lanza district I forgot to
mention district 9 uh I'll tell you what
I don't like about district 9 well first
of all the style it's a cool idea I like
what if aliens did land and we saw a
tree that realistically insert a
handheld ax that's interesting what I
don't like is well first of all I hate
of what people say you don't get it no
how could anyone not get this this is
the most obvious sense avatar this is
the most obvious symbolism in the world
you know that again about prejudice
about stuff that's going on in other
countries where you know they they treat
people like crap simply because of
whatever color of their skin or what
they believe and they just decide we're
gonna whatever beat them and just put
them in the slums and treat them like
shit I know this stuff happens I know um
why didn't you just make a documentary
about that instead of making it about
aliens which doesn't add up in the story
and I'll see this is why it's bad
symbolism symbolism works where even if
you don't know what the symbolism is the
story still works Animal Farm that's a
great example because even if you don't
know about you know Stalin and stuff
like that it's still a good story and
you can follow it okay if in a movie
like district 9 these aliens land and
then just what they just leave them why
the aliens can't speak English why why
they just throw them in the neighborhood
why don't they study them why don't they
talk too loudly try to communicate why
don't they try all this stuff they just
give up that's not realistic we wouldn't
do that
we're obsessed with going in space and
bajillion times were obsessed with look
at our molecules and see what we can
find
we're just giving up on the fucking
aliens the fucking aliens I mean beyond
unrealistic and of course it's to get
their message across which is so
painfully obvious but they think it's
really clever and people watching think
it so it's it's symbolic it's saying
something well obviously that doesn't
make it good um the the the style ah
everything is really original no every
scene every ten minutes there's a new
style and you can point out what it is
at first it's the office then becomes
Blair Witch that becomes alienation then
it becomes transformers then it becomes
you know whatever Independence Day and
it keeps going through all these movies
and style and just grabbing what it
likes and somehow people think that's
really original but it's not saying
anything original the characters aren't
original they're not even that
interesting and I think by again dark
comedy if you want to have it go more
serious okay I'm cool for it
the switch is so fast out of the blue
and painfully obvious the only reason I
sat through this movie is because people
kept saying it was so good when I was
intrigued by the trailers - okay well
let's see this and it was I really will
walked out if not so many people said
it's really good and really innovative
I'm saying what is this billing -
because there have been movies that I
paid in muscle way through but then I
got to the ending Wow that changed
everything
so I'm saying they're waiting for that
change to happen when is this gonna be a
great movie cuz it's really pissing me
off
and it never happened it was the message
in the first two minutes I heard this
was based on a short film you know what
I bet it'd be a much better short film
cuz that's how long it takes to get the
message across you don't need a movie
for this there's only one thing it did
that was original and I like I wish the
movie was about this I have never seen a
a lien
single father never seen that that was
fascinating I'm cared about those two
those are the only characters I wanted
to seek it out okay
and you know again at the end the
spaceships just standing there and what
the father had the key and started they
didn't think to tell anybody and why did
the aliens come there to begin with like
all these question all these plot all
these plot points that don't add up I
can't even remember them all look them
up there's a bajillion of plot points
that don't add up and they don't make
sense but what what gets me about this
movie and you'll probably see with a lot
of these movies a lot of movies on this
list is that I hate movies that think
they're saying something new and you
know mind-boggling and Wow
once people see this things are going to
change they think they're saying that
and they're not or they're at least not
saying it in a new way they're saying it
the way a bajillion people have said it
or they're taking stuff from other
sources hoping that'll make it a new way
that's really not it's just recycling in
that fucking singer the same singer that
was an avatar gladiator a lot of these
other bad films you know what I'm
talking about I did a Christmas special
video about it before it's the singer
that just goes yeah
and some sort of African made up
bullshit or if it's not made up I don't
care I am sick of that singer just you
hear him or her I could believe either
singing whenever there's this really you
know incredible moment where the dead
body is there and someone's looking from
the chapter going and then we cut to
whatever fields of grain and it's all a
yellow and gray me and you hear that
sing or that fucking singing yeah ooh
really 8,000 earthing I forgot to bring
up about Avatar when that fucking singer
showed up I'm like goddamn that's the
ultimate cliche I'm so sick of that
singer so I'm trying to think if there's
anything else about this movie because a
lot of people even though I thought I'd
stay very clearly what I didn't like
about that movie a lot of people are
really shocked that I still didn't like
it and don't get the reason so I I think
that's all I can really do it's it's
just it's an unpleasant movie on top of
that the comedies not very funny um all
the social satire they're trying to do
doesn't work because it doesn't work in
the world you know even something like
Hot Shots you know or one of those
movies you know all the weird jokes they
do it works because they create a world
where that would happen this is supposed
to be our world like this is what would
happen if aliens really did land and
when you do that you gotta follow by our
world's rules and this movie doesn't it
doesn't take into account anything that
mankind would do if aliens really did
land it just tosses that side for its
obvious message so again love to see a
movie about judging people that really
is about analyzing why people judge each
other I'm not going to get it in these
movies um so I think that's the last I'm
gonna say about district 9 because I
can't think of anything else to say
about I mean only thing I can say is I
got it okay don't say I didn't get it I
got it
if
could get that's why I didn't like the
movie that much so hope hopefully I'm
sure they'll piss a lot people off but
hopefully uh that's more of a detail
reason why and the number one movie that
I hate but everybody else seems to like
his Moulin Rouge
oh god hate this movie this is up there
with one of my top ten least favorite
movies remember I saying before about
films that think they're saying
something really brand new and
innovative but it's been said of a
jillion times before and in better ways
this is one of those big movies this is
one where you know the message is just
you know follow your heart be in love
and stuff like that but they think that
by putting all these big effects and
musical numbers and recycling songs that
we heard bajillion times before song
badly is gonna make this somehow new and
it's not it's not it's not it's not it
is I I want to like this movie because I
like the idea behind this style I love
the sets i when I saw the pre before
this movie I thought I was going to love
and I thought this is going to be
awesome this is gonna be like a
live-action music video with this really
good story because this director I can't
have put all this money and all this
artistic expression into a bullshit
version of Titanic and that's what he
did it's Titanic even Titanic had
something better to offer because idlies
had the ship sinking and it had a little
bit history myself it was flawed this
mmm I mean okay I'm gonna think now this
is just me personally I by that time
movie musicals were not arrived even now
they're they're still pretty rare and
this movie was the first movie musical
to have a lot of money behind it to come
out in years I mean this is one that Wow
okay they really spent a lot of money
and no original songs or there was me
one or two or something like that I mean
they were all rehash songs and I've
gotten better to accept that this was
the
you know that's the style the movie was
going for it is to show the whole
certainly wide world of music all
together in this one place I do
understand that I don't think it works
effectively and for that to be the first
musical that came out in years and to
have no original songs at all that
really got under my skin that really
pissed me off and have a lot of them
sung and redone really badly the very
very few of imagina worked
um but I got better with that because
like I said that is service style thing
and it did get movie musicals going I
appreciate it for that uh what annoys me
about it is that it's the Titanic story
again the basic villain with just no
motivation but to be an ass and get what
he wants because he's you start doing
what he wants boring uh the young artist
who wants to learn about love has never
been in love so he wants to explore
boring Nicole Kidman good god this woman
who wants to be an actress that's her
big thing it even takes her out of that
performance when you know the guys like
then you will become she's like a real
actress and I'm thinking dude just well
you're flying you're doing somersaults
you're doing flips you're in it you're
saying people are praising you as a
goddess what fucking more could you want
this you spoiled little whore bag I mean
this is like the world you have the
fucking world and she wants to be a real
actress duh and I just mmm
she's boring I hate it when you find out
she has I forget ya know there's a scene
where she coughs and falls off um there
whatever she's swinging out okay
she's dead we all know she's dead this
is pretty much a bad version of La
bohme which some people would call rent
but I digress um and of course when she
finds out that bel bad guy the Duke
wants the the boyfriend killed uh of
course she doesn't tell him okay just
hey I'm leaving you because your life is
in danger or hey let's give town all
this stuff and it's like no she
just like I I can't see you anymore I
hate I hate those scenes than any
romantic comedy and anything I've been
doing romance where the couple thinks
they don't love each other because of
some misunderstanding I can't cuz then
they go off they think they hate each
other they go and pout and brood and
they play some pop song it's boring
boring boring we know what's gonna
happen they're gonna get bad together
why are you wasting our time with this
and that's what it seemed like it seemed
like for all this money all this style
has put into this movie it was wasting
our time it just seemed like you're not
it looks very different it looks very
new but it's in terms of story character
anything else it's not giving us
anything to write down to the music it
is recycled I mean literally it's the
exact same music so and the other thing
about the style is that I could not get
into it because it's I know I'm of like
whatever the MTV generation I couldn't
get into it because the editing was just
too fast
and these are massive big sets I want to
enjoy them I want to see them and you're
not you're pretty much just seeing this
you know then some peridot and there's
something go through the movie and it's
um go home you know and it's just that
all the way through why spend money and
all these big sets and costumes aside if
you're not gonna let us see it you're
just gonna cut away or move the camera
around and oh it's it's mostly the
pretentiousness that gives me the most
how many times have used the word love
you ever count it I mean it's got to be
unbelievable and the characters are
children they were written for children
and it thanks bye aunt thinks it's like
the biggest shit it's things like we're
just saying all you need is love and I
mean first of all that's not very
interesting message I'm sorry it's
really not I mean even that message if
you believe I don't sing I don't believe
it but even if you do there's much more
than that
I mean there's life gets in the way okay
I mean and may this movie was trying to
show that but a love it was okay but
what they're showing us getting away
wasn't life that was planned movie
bullshit I mean with the villain and uh
you know the comedic misunderstandings
and stuff like that no that's movie
that's not life and I think this film
thought it was showing maybe life
getting in the way of love but love will
shine through love conquers all and it
simply wasn't it was very contrived and
forced and this movie thought it was
giving us something grand and new and
big and it was simply style over
substance I guess it's what out there
just a great big bowl of style over
substance and this movie really didn't
think it was that I think what I say
that I don't mean like the director that
I have no idea of the directors thinking
I'm not going to add like I do um you
know any director I say the movie
because the movie store becomes like its
own entity like its own art form and for
me that's what I feel like it was trying
to do was trying to get across something
really big and groundbreaking and it's
just nonsense that we've seen a
bajillion times before and oh it annoys
me it really annoys me and I'm just
repeating myself so that's the one that
people really seem to enjoy and they
really seem to get into the love story
don't understand it myself but I'm not
going to force whatever the love stories
I like on people so I that film really
annoys me if you enjoy it honestly the
people that usually do enjoy it usually
enjoy it for the art direction and the
style and I can understand I can respect
that even people that say they like
avatar they it's for the locket I I can
respect that I can respect that and even
if you do like the love story whatever
good for you let live that you know love
conquers all life it's a wonderful
innocent thought
it just doesn't work for me so folks
those are the top ten movies that I hate
everybody else seems to love um maybe
you don't like me they're that great
doesn't say anything about you it
probably does but you know nothing that
anybody should really care about oh
there's no good movies or bamboo ease or
just movies you like and don't like and
I love your pricing what the hell you're
just cramping all my favorite movies
next week you get your revenge I'm gonna
do the top ten movies that I like
everybody else seems to hate just to
show that there's just as many so guys I
hope you enjoyed this list I hope it
wasn't too long for you I hope it and
babble too much I know I did but either
way thanks for watching and look forward
to next week when you can get your
revenge on me take care